thanks for joining guys make sure you
stick around to the enemy's will I share
a little bit more about Jubilee in this
series until then enjoy the episode
there is no making America great again
it implies that we want to go back to
racism I disagree it applies you want to
go back to having KKK out in a box a
like all white people think that way is
Islam
I am charity I am a social justice
advocate and a Democrat my name is
Michael I work as a fiduciary in the
finance industry and I'm a Republican my
name is hope I'm a political activist as
well as a student and I am a
conservative I'm Josh I'm a writer in
the film industry and I'm a Democrat my
name is Christy I'm a conservative and I
run a dating app called writer my name
is Alan Suarez I'm student and political
organizer and I am a Democrat so a lot
of times I do get told that I'm only a
conservative because my parents are when
in actuality they rarely talked about
politics
it wasn't until very recently that I
realized yeah my parents are
conservative they really wanted my
sisters and I to be able to come to our
own beliefs oh my god I do have pretty
much the same views as my parents but
I'm the first one to actually be able to
vote and be outward politically about my
views well I come from a low-income
family my dad's disabled and they tried
and they fought very hard to keep me in
a good school so I can critically think
on my own and constantly questioned and
challenged my believe my beliefs and the
views of society why did you decide to
lean left
I'd say primarily where I was but I did
give both a chance I read both platforms
and I said I think I agree with more the
left than I do with the right but with
that being said of course not one side
is completely correct people who are in
my situation I feel for them and I want
to be able to help them out and I know
there's other mexican-americans or other
people who is gonna be there first time
voting and I want to make sure that they
have a right path and they know why do
you think Republicans don't want to help
no Republican have reached out to me I
see yeah I don't doubt that Republicans
want to help I never got that
opportunity we just try to help with
with jobs that's why I would say
groves I guess I'm the the unicorn stand
out here and that there's a very clear
political difference between me and my
parents I'm I grew up in a conservative
suburb in my first election I voted for
McCain because I got the talking points
every night and I was told about a
redistribution of wealth and that didn't
seem fair to me but then I got older I
started meeting people with different
perspectives and I started doing my own
research my party is misrepresented by
the media that everyone I think we can
all agree that news channels in general
can basically just suck there was a time
when Americans all lived in the same
information space and we could disagree
but at least we were disagreeing on the
same set of facts do you guys at least
accept there's a big media bias on both
sides not only for mostly for the left
though that the most of the media is in
support of the Left agenda Melania Trump
has yet to grace one cover of a magazine
really well Michelle Obama was on how
many covers 119 Michelle Obama mission
much more she heard she had a name sure
so she's a lawyer
milania's like this is not what I signed
so yeah MSNBC CNN NBC even CBS the list
goes on in general more media
organizations tend to be a little bit
more favorable towards the Democratic
position yes but I think to say the two
biases are the same the fake news on the
right is so much more blatant and I'll
come off you wish the left coin that
phrase
[Music]
take apart democrat or republican right
or left America is our country we all
live here we're all citizens
I don't laughed a little bit when we
heard the statement I want to make
America great again opposed to not make
America great again I have no
understanding or concept of how anyone
in this room could not want our country
to be great again the phrase make
America great again a plot implies that
America was great to begin with and if
it was great to begin with the question
is for who it wasn't great for
minorities it wasn't great for people of
color and you know you guys sit in a
position of privilege in a position of
whiteness where you can say that because
it was always great for you
absolutely I'm sorry you don't get to
speak for me I Wis panic are you talking
for mics you just pointed to all of us
they told us why did us but she passes
right
my mother was adopted out of Guatemala
and she wasn't for me you do not get
it's not directed to you I will not sit
here and be flown I got and told that I
am sitting in a position of white prison
about you that's the problem how was it
not about that about you I'm talking in
general I am talking in general is that
in general I would never sit in if you
let me talk I would be more than glad to
tell you that you better take better
care we can die don't tell me what I bet
her do thank you my point is when we
have a country that was built on the
backs of slavery the things I still feel
today as a black woman there is no
making America great again it implies
that we want to go back to racism hiding
racism because it still existed
it applies I want to go back to you know
having KKK out in about they have a
social media presence by having them as
I know I've been threatened by them
twice under Hitler has been elected when
I hear make America great again I think
he's just talking about the numbers
economic growth to say like all white
people think that way is is wrong it's
just talk about how when we won World
War two we defeated the Nazis we were
the best country in the world at the
time given the fact all the segregation
in the south so that's why I think it's
dangerous though because it's too broad
I just feel like even if he made it make
America economic again they would say oh
he's trying to take the minorities out
and make it more economically thing that
he would say they would attack we should
help the underprivileged
I think it's written in our basic rights
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness right everybody should be on
the same like level playing field right
especially the underprivileged who don't
have these kinds of opportunities they
might have grown up in an education
system that's not as good quality as
certain places and then do you think
that's almost a disservice to them
having to go to a college where they're
not almost prepared exactly didn't yeah
they were given though like the
opportunity because it may be like
affirmative action for example where
they get into that spot and then they're
like oh wow I'm kind of overwhelmed
there's a number of factors that we have
to consider you know if we're talking
about schools but first of all we don't
pay teachers enough so it's not exactly
attracting the best and brightest
individuals to raise our kids if you do
great as a teacher the incentive is to
move to a better school with students
who are already have economic advantages
for example I'd want voucher systems for
underprivileged kids to go to good
schools what makes them underprivileged
I would say economic status I guess my
question is why aren't the parents
working oh well maybe they came from a
situation where their mother was maybe
in prostitution or something well a lot
of kids are underprivileged because of
the socioeconomic status they come from
the way our systems in our districts are
set up it's you know keep the poor here
keep the rich here lack of opportunities
lack of education kids that are sex
trafficked or made primarily toasters
extra is very different but it turns
into llege but no but it turns into
adult prostitution that's that's
underprivileged too if you're coming if
you're a foster youth that's I I was
sexually exploited as a foster youth it
wasn't I wasn't prostituting but I was
sexually exploited and I when I was
incarcerated when I was a teenager I was
incarcerated with dozens of little girls
that were in jail for being sexually
exploited by grown man so even as we
touch on the me to movement these are
people that are getting away with you
know the me to movement
in Hollywood with actresses that were
paid millions of dollars by a dream
everywhere now what yours talk to you
about is very different it originated
there but it gave way to everyone need
to move it needed to happen a lot of
ways absolutely when it came out even
though it happened in Hollywood I went
on social media and put hash tag me too
it empowered me it gave me a voice it
made me felt like I wasn't dirty or I
did something wrong I'm okay finally
with being vulnerable and telling a
story about something that impacted me
as a child and that impact did not just
me but thousands maybe millions of girls
actually I'm coming in I can't remember
if it was the first time Obama was
elected or the second time but I do
remember I was in middle school and a
girl came up got into my face and was
like you're gonna cry because your
president wasn't elected I felt very
attacked and very unsafe in that moment
I would say mine was a little bit more
life in death situation I was attacked
outside of a restaurant and stabbed four
times back in the night so I just wish I
could open carry and protect myself more
effectively that's why I feel like the
other side's agenda kind of put me in
harm's way I have a second Amendment
right and I have a right to carry and I
don't see it any different really well
personally I'm not a person who believes
that we need to get rid of the Second
Amendment I think that's okay false
stereotype that's propagated upon
explain yes if I'm with my children and
I'm by myself and or whatever the case
is I'm being stabbed bet your bottom
dollar if I have a gun I'm going to use
it but I'm not gonna use a gun on
someone just because they're in my where
I feel threatening are the idea of them
are you no I'm not but that's what's
happening and that's you know yours is
an exception and I'm so sorry that
happened but when we've seen people
getting killed you know when we see what
happened to Trayvon Martin you know when
we see what's happening in the world
it's because of you know as an identity
as a person ed because of the color of
my skin I'm a threat to you I think it's
really about gun safety because we're
not about taking away the Second
Amendment we're just about making it
safer for people to hold arms or for
backgrounds yes for background check I
just said forward because has the agenda
the other side's agenda personally
harmed you and so what from what I hear
and I don't mean to like to show you our
discredit it seems like the other
someone from the other side attacked you
but not the agenda the one area that
might harm me is immigration I come from
a family of immigrants they're all
illegal now and so it personally hasn't
heartened me but I have very many
friends and family friends that that
have had trouble with this but
personally I have not been harmed I know
that what happened to me had nothing to
do with the last agenda and I'm sorry
it's just um and but still at the same
time I did feel attacked
I felt unsafe at a school I had gone to
since kindergarten this country by the
only one I would say that people want
health care for all they want college
for all when in reality someone has to
pay for it I'm okay with the schools
being public I'm okay with the streets
being cleaned or you know the police
force being paid by tax dollars but that
necessarily doesn't need to apply to the
whole system I think people want
socialism but the country certainly is
not a socialist and it never will be
yeah the country I think that just like
Millennials though I would say a large
portion want it and as a millennial I'm
just gonna say I don't like to put the
labels on things I don't want to say we
want a socialist society we want a
society where we have access to
opportunities regardless of party
regardless of race when the Affordable
Care Act was implemented you know I
immediately saw that I was paying more
out of pocket all of us look there's
this coinsurance I got to pay for it no
one likes paying more money but I
understood the reason why I understood
that it benefitted people that are less
fortunate
more than likely and this is my opinion
that Republicans are often you know what
benefits me as an individual versus
society as a whole no I think I care
about myself for sure as anyone should
but collectively I want America to be
great again but with Republicans
everything is
fine and Dan you give more jobs give
more healthcare give XY and Z but then
the second a personally affects me and
that I have to pay more taxes Trump just
introduced a new budget what two days
ago that gave Medicare that could
healthcare that cuts social service
programs to build a wall that protects
the nation we live in what protects the
nation is making sure we have access to
health care education the president I'm
someone that's been negatively impacted
by not having self education we all have
we all have been negatively impacted
negatively impacted by someone that
crossed the border illegally yes I sir
yes yeah someone trying to break into
her man you know he was undocumented
yeah because he worked at her job along
with many of the illegal aliens that
worked in her company consistently she
was being sexually abused she told her
boss they didn't do [ __ ] and then
finally they he got so drunk or whatever
he followed her home and he tried to
break into her apartment those things do
happen but it's not an immigration
problem if you have a good job or you
have a job you should be allotted health
care from the business okay what what's
wrong with that if you have a job why
don't you have a job
there's a lot of wises why people don't
have a job now with the type of job to
access to jobs you know it's it's a real
life training to have jobs so something
that not a lot of people think about is
what about automation right there's a
company in San Francisco that says if
it's repeatable its replaceable so about
all those people are going to lose their
jobs
and so how are they gonna get Medicare
how are they gonna have an education
system well then you have to get into
the one of the fields that isn't gonna
be replaced that's what I was gonna pay
for their education so they can switch
their fields learn the code but it
should be your right now that's right
though it to be in this country it is a
privilege yeah it is your privilege okay
it is not a right having a job is not a
right insurance is not a right College
is not a right now every man Jesus
please found a way all right I'm gonna
pause there because this is the final
prompt and I am very curious to see what
everybody says for this
if you would like I said I wanted pizza
is this nation too divided yes I
shouldn't have to lose friends over my
political views that's a prime example
of just how divided our nation is my son
we worked on the Trump campaign and we
worked with Don Trump jr. and our car
was key twice because I had a trump
sticker on my truck on my car we were
obviously at theater inauguration my
daughter was in a black tie we went to
the inaugural ball of course and on our
way there she was spat on literally had
spit from one of the protesters for spit
on my daughter 16 I don't know what you
would do as a mother I lost say on
camera oh yeah well I did the exact same
thing I was just like really like this
is where we are that was wrong and that
shouldn't happen you know that shouldn't
happen to anyone we need to know how to
disagree and respect each other's
parties and that happens on both sides
Trump supporters do the same thing to us
but it's not okay in any instance we
shouldn't be spitting on people we
should we should set examples and it
starts with us I think it's something
that we definitely need to focus more on
the at least willing to come to the
table and have a conversation even if we
have different viewpoints because we
will inevitable but at least come in and
talk about him and recognize that while
we do have different solutions we have
the same issues I'm actually gonna give
you a hug
the media it talks - you know as much
conflict as there was I think that was
still really valuable
it feels really real to what's happening
right now in our country especially with
the country getting more and more
divided us trying to bring people
together and you guys helped us so much
with that thank you again for watching
our series watch our content everything
that we put up tell us what kind of
episodes you'd like to see what you
think of the prompts in the episode we
do read all the comments that's right
and as always make sure you like you
subscribe tell your friends tell your
mom tell everyone tell everyone always
make sure to live deeper so yes alright
peace